[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm Liz Cohen.
I'm Dean of the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study.
And I couldn't be happier
to welcome all of you
to a unique format today for
this year's Rama S. Mehta
program, entitled "Families in
Flight-- Today's International
Refugee Crisis".
The Rama S. Mehta Lecture was
established by the late John
Kenneth Galbraith and
Catherine Atwater Galbraith
in memory of Rama S. Mehta, a
scholar of modern Indian family
life.
I'm pleased to welcome the
Galbraiths' son, Ambassador
Peter Galbraith, who's
sitting here in the front row.
[APPLAUSE]
Along with two of Rama
Mehta's granddaughters,
[? Molika ?] Mehta and
[? Ahilia ?] Mehta.
Since--
[APPLAUSE]
Right there.
There they are, over there.
Great.
Well, we're just so happy
to have you all here.
Since 1981, the
Mehta lecture has
brought distinguished
public figures to Cambridge
to address pressing
contemporary issues concerning
women in the developing world.
It would be hard to think
of a more urgent issue today
than the global refugee crisis.
At the end of 2014,
the UN estimated
that one out of every
122 people on earth
was displaced and
seeking refuge or asylum.
We are fortunate to have a
distinguished panel of experts
to address this critical
subject with us today.
I think the fact that
so many of you are here
is a testament to how important
we all know this issue is.
I especially want to welcome
members of the classes of 1971,
1976, and 1986.
These are Harvard
classes who have returned
to Harvard for their reunions.
Welcome also to members
of the Class of 1962,
who will celebrate
their reunion in May.
I'd like to thank
the Harvard Alumni
Association for its partnership
in today's event, which has
made your presence possible.
As Harvard's Institute
for Advanced Study,
Radcliffe fosters
interdisciplinary inquiry
into important and
multifaceted subjects.
We bring together
leading thinkers
from across the Harvard
campus and around the world
to investigate questions that
transcend any one Harvard
school or any one discipline.
And we are committed to
sharing innovative work
with the broadest community
possible through public events
like this one today,
and many others.
For example, we will hold
an annual science symposium.
This year it's
entitled "From Sea
to Changing Sea-- A Science
Symposium About Oceans", which
will take place on Friday,
October 28th at 9 o'clock,
right here in this room
in the Knafel Center.
The calendar cards
on your chairs
list many more events
coming up this fall.
I hope you'll join us
for as many of them
as you can, either
here in Cambridge
or through our website, where
we livestream many of our events
and we post videos of
more of them afterwards.
You can also use the website
to register for events.
Our programs are always
free and open to the public,
but we do request
that you register
so we can provide the most
comfortable accommodations.
Our events and all of our
work here at Radcliffe
depends on the generosity
of our supporters.
I'm grateful to the donors from
every Radcliffe and Harvard
class who make it possible
for the Radcliffe Institute
to probe deeply and share
widely our inquiry into the most
vital world issues.
So just why is the refugee
question so urgent today?
Displacement, after all,
is an ageless problem.
One of the world's most
ancient written stories
is about exiles journeying
through the desert for 40
years, and numerous oral
traditions similarly
locate their society's origins
in banishment and wandering.
The refugee crisis of the
20th and 21st centuries,
however, are truly something
new and different under the sun.
Our modern category
of refugee status
only emerged with the
rise of the nation
state, which by
definition created
its opposite statelessness.
The first people to
be uprooted by war
and identified as refugees
with a claim on the conscience
of the world were Belgians
in World War I. Sadly,
not many years later, even
more massive numbers of people
were displaced by World
War II, heightening
worldwide sensitivity to the
need for systematic refugee
relief, and inspiring
the United Nations
to issue the Declaration
of Human Rights in 1948.
But official coordinated relief
operations took two more years
to materialize.
The United Nations High
Commission for Refugees,
the UNHCR, was
established in 1950.
The first emergency that
the UNHCR responded to
was the Hungarian
uprising of 1956,
an event within the
lifetime and memory of some
of the people in this room.
Today, there are more
than 65 million forcibly
displaced people worldwide.
Nearly 34,000 people flee
their homes each day.
Most of them seek
refuge somewhere
in Africa or the Middle East.
Fewer than 20% enter
Europe or the Americas.
About 80% of the
world's refugees
are women and children.
Let's look closely
at one example
for a better sense of
exactly what displacement
means for them.
Drought and war in
Somalia robbed a woman
named Isha and her family
of the livestock that
had once made them prosperous.
When they had nothing left,
Isha and her five young children
walked through the
desert to Dadaab,
62 miles inside
the Kenyan border.
By the time they arrived, the
skin of the children's feet
had been entirely worn away.
Dadaab opened in 1991 as a
temporary camp for the 90,000
Somalis that the UN estimated
would be uprooted by warfare
in their home country.
Today, Dadaab houses nearly half
a million people-- Sudanese,
Ethiopians, Congolese,
and Ugandans,
as well as Somalis-- making
it the third largest city
population-wise in Kenya.
It has schools, hospitals,
and a commercial economy.
But camps themselves
are problematic.
Infectious disease,
supply shortages,
and gender-based
violence run rampant.
Camps also require toleration
by their host countries,
and that tolerance
may not last forever.
The Kenyan government, in
fact, has announced plans
to close Dadaab.
The current president of the
International Rescue Commission
recommends that
camps be replaced
with greater support
to host countries
to integrate newcomers into the
mainstream of their societies.
Yet recent events in Europe, not
to mention our own government's
response to migrants
crossing our southern border,
show that hopes for a warmer
welcome may not be realistic.
The most pressing refugee
crisis in recent months
has been the one created by the
violent unrest in Syria, which
has resulted in 13
million Syrian refugees.
In today's panel, experts
close to that crisis
will share their
expertise and insight
into this crisis and other
refugee situations with us.
Notably, one of our
panelists is a photographer,
a testament to
Radcliffe's commitment
to the arts as contributing
in crucial ways
to deeper knowledge
and understanding
of important issues
like this one.
So here's how the
day is going to work.
Jacqueline Bhabha will
introduce the participants
and moderate the discussion.
Jackie is a professor of the
Practice of Health and Human
Rights at the Harvard TH
Chan School of Public Health,
and Director of Research at the
FHB Center for Health and Human
Rights here at Harvard.
And I have to say, she
is also a great friend
of the Radcliffe Institute.
The panel will conclude with
a question and answer period.
We'll be setting up a
microphone in the center aisle.
I ask if you have a
question that you step up
to the microphone.
There'll be a line behind it.
Introduce yourself and
then ask your question.
After the panel, I
hope you will join us
for our continued discussion
at a reception in Faye
House, which is our main
administrative building here
at the Radcliffe
Institute, right next door.
Once again, thank you
so much for coming.
And now join me in
welcoming Jackie Bhabha.
[APPLAUSE]
-Hello, and welcome.
Liz, thank you so much for your
very erudite and appropriate
introduction.
Radcliffe always
manages to choose
topics which are really
of critical importance
to many of us at the University.
And as you said, you
span many disciplines,
but you always seem to
hit the nail on the head.
So congratulations
for choosing something
which I think touches
so many of us so deeply,
and that we're also
concerned about.
Thank you also for
putting together
a really wonderful panel.
I think the expertise
on the panel,
as you will hear in a second,
and the range of experiences
that people will
bring to it, are going
to enrich our conversation.
I just wanted to
make, and I know
this is-- going to be
very concise, so don't
worry about the schedule.
But I just wanted to make
three very brief points
before I introduce our panel.
First, to say that even
though our title today is
"Families in Flight", I'm sure
we're all aware of the fact
that many, many of those
fleeing are regrettably
not in families, they're alone.
They've either lost the
rest of their family,
or they've been separated
from their family,
or they've been sent
alone by their family.
So as we think
about this problem,
and as our colleagues
address it,
I think it's
important to realize
how fraught the social
context is, not only because
of the displacement, but
also because of the loss
of the surrounding
familiar environment.
The second point I
wanted to make briefly
is-- and I'm very glad
you mentioned this, Liz--
that we are all so
focused, rightly,
on the tragedy unfolding every
day in Syria, and in Aleppo
at the moment, in particular,
but of course, there
are extraordinarily serious
refugee crises elsewhere, too,
which we neglect.
So South Sudan, for
example, the newest member
state of the United Nations,
is in a state of acute conflict
and thousands are fleeing
South Sudan every day.
A conflict we don't
hear much about.
But as we think
about this crisis,
we need to really have a
global picture in mind.
And finally, I wanted
to say how important it
is that we have a
photographer amongst us,
those of us who spend most
our time with written words.
Because as we all know,
it was a photograph
in this particular Syrian
context that really
shifted the compass
so dramatically,
and really forced policy makers
to get outside their policy
talk and think about the
humanitarian crisis, at least
for a short period.
So the role of photography
couldn't be more critical,
I think, to persuading
politicians to just
take seriously the
humanitarian impact.
So let me briefly introduce
altogether our speakers
in the order in which they're
going to be addressing us.
First of all, I'm delighted to
welcome Dr. Noel Calhoun, who's
a senior policy officer
who has been working
with the Special
Advisor for the Summit
on addressing large numbers
of refugees and migrants
at the United Nations.
That's quite a mouthful,
but basically, she
was critically involved
in this big, first ever
summit at the UN addressing
this large-scale migration
on the 19th of September.
So we're very lucky
to have her insights.
She now is going to be taking
up the position of Deputy
Representative of
UNHCR in Ukraine,
and she comes to us also as
a Harvard alum with an MA
and a PhD from this university.
Our second speaker is a close
friend and colleague, Dr. Susan
Akram, who is Clinical Professor
of Law at Boston University Law
School, and directs their
international human rights
clinic.
She's a must-go-to person for
anyone working on refugees,
and has a long history of
doing extraordinary work,
particularly on questions
relating to the Middle East,
to Palestine, and to other
conflicts in the area.
She was recognized with a
Fulbright Senior Scholar
Teaching and Research Award
some years ago for the research
she's done, and she continues to
work not only on Middle Eastern
issues, but also, for
example, on representing
some of the people who've
been detained in Guantanamo.
So she has both a very
impressive scholarly track
record, but also is
a practitioner who
is at front line, so to speak.
Thirdly, we have
Abdulkarim Ekzayez,
who is a health program manager
from Save the Children's Syria
response.
He's actually from--
I presume he's
from Aleppo, because
he got his education
at the University of Aleppo.
And he is now based in
Turkey, but obviously makes
frequent trips to
Syria, and is involved
in a set of critical
campaigns, including campaigns
to ensure that a higher
proportion than is
the case right now of Syrian
children are immunized.
Some of you may be aware that
this drop in vaccination rates
has been one of the
most concerning health
correlates of the conflict.
So thank you for joining us.
And finally, last but
certainly not least,
Rania Matar, our
independent photographer,
who was born and
raised in Lebanon,
and is an architect by
training, but is now
a full-time
photographer, and also
a teacher at the Massachusetts
College of Art and Design.
She has a very long list
of credits to her name
of exhibitions that her
work has been involved in,
including, some of you may
have seen here at the MFA,
the exhibition on
women from Iran,
and other exhibitions
dealing with Arab women.
She is currently part
of an exhibition called
"Aftermath-- The Fallout of
War-- America in the Middle
East", curated by
Carol McCusker.
She's clearly been recognized
for much of the work
she's done, including
receiving the 2011 Legacy
Award at the Griffin
Museum of Photography
for the photographic
work she's done.
So thank you all so
much for joining us,
and perhaps you can all
come up and sit next to me
on the panel.
[APPLAUSE]
-Good afternoon.
I wish to thank the
Radcliffe Institute
for hosting an event on
the issue of refugees.
I want to share with you
today from my experience
of the process of
the preparations
for the summit that
was held at the United
Nations just a month ago.
But before that,
to talk a little
bit about the scope
of the problem.
I think we've already
had the stage set for us,
these numbers of 65
million displaced.
That's a big number.
As we heard, it's actually now
1% of the world's population.
65 million is equivalent to
the population of the United
Kingdom, for example.
And often, you'll
hear the comparison
that this is the largest
number of displaced persons
since the Second World War.
And I'd like to reflect
on that, because actually,
the population now is three
times greater than what
it was at the time of
the Second World War.
And also, the economies of the
rich countries in the world
have not been devastated.
So really, this
should be a challenge
that we can
collectively cope with,
as well as our
forefathers and mothers
did after the Second World War.
Of these 65 million, 21
million are actually refugees,
meaning that they've crossed
an international border.
The others are displaced
within their own country,
including many Syrians
who are displaced
within their own country.
And five million Syrians,
or about a quarter
of the world's refugees,
are displaced from Syria.
So not only are
the numbers large,
but the responsibility for
hosting the world's refugees
is not shared fairly at all.
When we read the press
or read the newspapers,
we get the sense
that there are lots
of refugees coming into
Europe and living in the US.
But that impression is skewed,
because as we've heard,
the vast majority of
the world's refugees
are in developing countries.
In fact, eight
countries in the world,
all of them in
Africa or Asia, host
half of the world's refugees.
From their perspective,
this just isn't fair.
Why do they end up
hosting these refugees?
Well, it's really an
accident of geography.
Because of their
proximity to countries
that are engulfed
in conflict, they
are the first
responders, and receiving
large numbers of refugees.
And they host them
for a very long time.
Displacement is becoming
more and more protracted.
Of the 21 million
refugees, how many
were able to actually
go home last year?
That's the real success.
I'm a UNHCR staff
person, I've been
working on refugee
issues for 15 years,
and the big success
for us is when
refugees can go home
and rebuild their lives.
But last year, only
200,000 refugees
were able to return
to their homes.
And over this last
year, we've seen
a lack of a coherent response
to these increased numbers.
States are reacting
to refugee flows
with unilateral and highly
restrictive measures.
They're looking for different
ways to deter entry,
to restrict rights, to
detain asylum seekers,
and to put up walls that are
both figurative and literal.
We see that this causes
immense human suffering,
that it violates human rights.
And we also see that it's a
cause of dispute among states.
And this calls out for an
international solution,
for multilateral approaches
to solving problems.
And this became even more
clear in the last year,
in 2015, which was a
particularly horrible year
for refugees, when we saw people
drowning in the Mediterranean.
We saw boats adrift
in the Andaman Sea,
looking for a safe harbor
where people could disembark.
We saw dangerous land journeys,
not only in the Sahara,
but closer to our home
here in Central America.
And then, the rising problems of
protracted displacement, people
being displaced for 5,
10, 20, even more, years.
And then, the impact
that all of this
was having on politics,
particularly in Europe, but now
also in the United
States, where debates
about resettlement of
Syrians have become
a matter of national concern.
Over the past year--
I mean now we're
coming to the end
of the year, and it
is a time when we can
start to look back at 2016,
and reflect on what has
happened so far this year,
and where things need to go--
there has been an attempt
to revitalize a multilateral
response to refugee movement.
So what has happened
over the past year,
starting in February
of this year,
there was a major
conference to raise funds
for the countries that are
supporting Syrian refugees,
and $12 billion was
pledged at that conference
for Syrian refugees and the
countries that host them.
The next month, the
UN refugee agencies
gathered states to try to
persuade them to increase
resettlement numbers, so
that more Syrian refugees
could benefit from resettlement
to third countries.
The actual results of
that were quite modest,
but it takes time for countries
to start a program like that,
a resettlement program.
And now we're
starting to see, as we
come to the end of the year,
that more states are pledging
to start resettlement programs
or to increase their numbers.
Something that many
countries, especially Turkey--
I know Karim is
working in Turkey--
are very interested
in seeing increases.
We had the World Humanitarian
Summit in May of this year
in Istanbul to try
to improve the way
that humanitarian
and development
workers address refugee crises.
And then, on the
20th of September,
so the day after the UN
Summit, President Obama
hosted what was called the
Leaders Summit on Refugees,
and this brought together
some 52 countries
that were really ready to make
substantial pledges in terms
of humanitarian funding,
resettlement places,
and education and employment
opportunities for refugees.
So really, there has been
a great deal of attention
to try to improve a multilateral
response to the Syrian refugee
crisis.
But as Jackie has mentioned,
this is not only about Syria.
And in fact, there can
be negative repercussions
if we focus only on
one refugee crisis.
As we were involved in the
intergovernmental negotiations
leading up to the Summit
on the 19th of September,
we also heard from
many countries
that have been hosting
refugees for a very long time,
and who feel that the
attention to Syrian refugees
is somehow putting
them at a disadvantage.
And that can lead to the
squeezing of the protection
space for refugees
in those countries.
So there is a recognition
that we can't only just keep
having pledging conferences
and raising money, and maybe
increasing our
resettlement numbers,
but we need to think
about longer-term issues
and global trends.
And on refugees,
the global trends
are these permanent shortfalls
in humanitarian funding,
the length of displacement,
and the disproportionate strain
on a few countries.
And then there's also
migration more generally.
International migration
is a growing global trend,
but the governance structure
for international migration
is really in its infancy.
We have better systems
internationally
for governing the movements
of goods and services
than we do for governing
the movement of people.
And yet, international
migration has traditionally
been an issue that
member states do not
want to discuss in
the United Nations,
because it is considered a
closely guarded attribute
of national sovereignty, and
not something to be discussed
in a multilateral forum.
So the goals of
the Summit that we
held on the 19th of September
at the General Assembly
was really to
agree on some tools
for sharing responsibility
for the world's refugees,
and to bring the
issue of migration
into a multilateral
forum, and to start work
toward a governance structure
for international migration.
Now, this Summit occurs in
an intergovernmental context,
and it occurs in the
General Assembly.
And that institutional
context is
important to understand
what actually
happened at the Summit.
The General Assembly is unique
as an international body,
in that it brings
together all 193 member
states with a one-state,
one-vote principle.
And decisions in
the General Assembly
are taken by consensus.
That means we try to
get everybody to agree.
In the last week,
I've been trying
to get 20 of my colleagues
to agree on a document
and I've been struggling.
When you try to do that
in the General Assembly,
with 193 members states
with very diverse interests,
it's quite a challenge.
However, the member
states agreed early on
in the negotiations
that they didn't
want to just have the president
of the General Assembly
write a summary of their
summit and be done with it.
They actually wanted
to negotiate a text.
And so we spent
the summer working
under the leadership of
the ambassadors of Jordan
and Ireland.
We spent the summer
trying to negotiate
this text among states.
And they really bring very
different perspectives,
from the states that hosts a
lot of refugees-- I'm trying
to see how this clock works.
-You've only got five seconds.
-Five seconds.
Oh, dear.
[LAUGHTER]
What we ended up with out of
this very difficult negotiation
was a document that
underlines certain commitments
to the human rights of
all refugees and migrants,
reaffirms the 1951
Convention for Refugees.
It sets up a-- it agrees on a
comprehensive refugee response
plan, and sets forth the
elements for that plan,
so that we focus not only on
short-term humanitarian needs,
but longer-term development
needs of countries
that are hosting refugees.
And we have a two-year
process to agree
on what we're calling a Global
Compact on Refugees that
will establish a fairer system
for sharing responsibility
among countries.
We also have a similar process,
an intergovernmental process,
on migration that
we hope will lead
to a global compact
for safe, orderly,
and regular migration by 2018,
and so negotiations on that
are getting started in New York.
But I would just end by saying
that that political declaration
adopted in New York, it
does have a legitimacy,
it represents a commitment,
but it's not legally binding.
What it takes to make
the states accountable
is action on lots
of different levels.
And I know from
working in the field
that the most important
action is really
from the civil
society organizations,
and from ordinary citizens
who raise these issues, who
make the situation of refugees
very real, and press for states
to live up to the commitments
that they made in New York
on the 19th of September.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
-Thank you all for coming.
It's quite amazing to
have this number of people
interested in refugees.
Those of us who feel like we're
always talking to ourselves
can be sometimes gratified
by talking to others.
So I'm going to
move the discussion
from the more political
orientation to a framework
of looking at the Syrian crisis
from the point of view of what
the law has to say about it.
And as you've heard already of
the global refugee total, that
is convention refugees,
documented now by the United
Nations High Commissioner
for Refugees,
is 21 million people in 2016.
Syria represents 22% of
that refugee population.
It's the largest source
country for refugees
in the world today.
And as of September
30th, UNHCR figures
show 4.8 million total
persons from Syria registered
in the region, 2
million in Turkey alone,
and the balance of those in
Jordan, Lebanon, Iraq, Egypt,
and the rest of North Africa.
Now, these figures have to be
understood in context as well.
Lebanon and Jordan,
along with Syria,
already hosted the
majority of the world's
Palestinian refugees
for over 60 years.
More than 2 million registered
in Jordan, half a million
in Lebanon, over half
a million in Syria
before the crisis in 2011.
Now one person in four
in Lebanon is a refugee.
While in Jordan, one
of the most water
stressed countries in the world,
with insufficient capacity
to provide water and other basic
resources to its own people,
one quarter of the
population is refugees.
And that bears some
thinking about when
we are talking about the numbers
that the United States is
looking at on its
southern border.
Despite incredible efforts to
provide for the Syrian refugee
influx, Jordan and Lebanon have
long since exceeded capacity
to absorb more refugees, and
both countries quite recently
closed their borders with Syria.
What's particularly interesting
from a legal point of view
is that the main host countries
to the Syrians fleeing the war
had no applicable refugee and
asylum frameworks in place
before 2011.
Lebanon and Jordan
are not parties
to the main international
treaty governing
the rights and status of
refugees, the 1951 Refugee
Convention.
And although Egypt and Turkey
are parties to the convention,
they have carved out
significant exceptions
to its application that have
affected the status of Syrians
as refugees.
As a result, all of these
states treated Syrians
as irregular migrants,
short-term visitors,
or in other statuses
with policies
that have fluctuated over time.
For the first four
years of the crisis,
these governments did not
conceive of incoming Syrians
as refugees, per se.
As guests, migrants, displaced
civilians, or more recently,
as a result of a major
change in the law in Turkey,
persons under temporary
protection status.
As such, even without
formal refugee policies,
all the frontline states,
until the end of last year,
were extremely generous in
opening their territories
to the refugees, establishing
almost open-door policies,
together hosting the almost
4 million refugees as best
they could.
So what changed?
These basically
open-door policies
towards refugees from
the states in the region
have become a closed-door policy
towards new Syrian entrance
over the last approximately
year and a half.
And the key factor
in this change
are the policies imposed
by Western states
to stem the flood of refugees
from moving beyond the region.
As Noel discussed,
billions of dollars
have been raised and spent
already on this crisis.
As of last September,
Turkey's government
claimed it had spent
already 5.37 billion euros
of its own money, well exceeding
the entire donation of the EU
by then to the crisis.
But all of the financial
plans, and a host
of European and Western
policies concerning refugees,
focus on a paradigm
of containment,
ensuring the refugee crisis
remains in the region.
Restrictive policies in
Europe and the Americas,
including the EU
Schengen and Dublin
rules, that penalize
illegal border crossers
and prevent access
to refugee status,
have created extremely
dangerous barriers
to Syrian asylum seekers.
As a result of these barriers,
more than 7,500 people
have died trying to make
the risky sea crossing
to Europe since 2014.
Two children drown
on average every day
in the Mediterranean or
Aegean trying to reach Europe.
The extremely generous policies
that Turkey, Lebanon, Jordan,
and even Egypt had put in place
at the start of the crisis
began rapidly reversing
as a direct result
of the failure of states
outside the region
to share responsibility for a
portion of the refugee flow.
While these countries are
hosting over 4 million
of the 5 million
Syrian refugees,
the EU has asked
the European states
to pledge no more than 160,000
resettlement slots for refugees
from Syria, Iraq, and Eritrea.
And so far, no more than
270,000 asylum applications
have been submitted by
Syrians all across Europe.
And resettled refugees and
asylum seekers in the EU
represent far less than 10% of
the Syrian refugee population.
The US administration's
recent announcement
that it would accept
an additional 10,000
Syrian refugees this
year, though welcome,
is also an extremely
small expansion
to the US's 70,000 yearly
global refugee ceiling,
and contributes little
to relieving the crisis.
The latest EU-Turkey agreement
to send refugees back
who survived the risky
journey by sea or land
from Turkey to Europe
with a 3 billion
euro financial incentive
and a, quote unquote,
"refugee exchange plan",
is only the latest
of the Western policies
of containment.
The EU-Turkey agreement, the
combined Dublin-Schengen rules,
and push-back policies in
the Eastern European states
are major elements of the
containment paradigm currently
driving the Middle
East refugee dynamic.
Meanwhile, major barriers
in US refugee law,
such as the over-expansive
material support
for terrorism bars
that prevent thousands
of legitimate refugees from
being admitted to this country,
mean that hundreds
of eligible Syrians
are waiting in limbo after being
granted refugee recognition
in the host states, while
the multi-agency vetting
process in the US wends
its way to conclusion.
The main thrust, then,
of these policies
is not protection of
the vulnerable migrants
and refugees who are
the subjects of it,
but a solidifying of
this containment paradigm
on which the US and the EU
have operated since the migrant
and refugee crisis
in the Middle East
made its way to
Europe and beyond.
In brief, the
policy's major focus
is to make sure the refugees
and migrants currently
hosted in the millions
by the neighboring states
remain there, and are
barred by whatever
means necessary from
leaving the region.
This is exactly the
opposite of the thrust
of the purpose of
the treaties that
bind the EU and the wider
community of European and most
Western states.
The primary and, of
course, most important
international legal
obligations towards refugees
arise from the 1951
Refugee Convention
and its companion
1967 Protocol, as one
or both of these
instruments bind
all the states in Europe,
the US, as well as Turkey.
The essential elements
of the Refugee Convention
are the obligation not to
return a refugee to a place
where she risks persecution,
non-refoulement,
the obligation of
each state party
to provide fair access
to asylum procedures
to refugees on a
nondiscriminatory basis,
and the prohibition against
collective expulsion.
These elements
are expanded under
European regional
instruments, such as the EU
Charter, the Civil and
Political Rights Treaty,
the European Convention
on Human Rights,
and decisions of the two
European courts, the Strasbourg
and the Luxembourg courts.
These courts have
further articulated
that collective expulsion
includes when a state removes
refugees and migrants from its
territory in any manner that
fails to provide them with
access to fair procedures
for international protection.
The prohibition against
collective expulsion
also includes removing
persons on the basis
of their national
or ethnic identity,
through pro forma proceedings,
or without access to counsel,
or where not appeal is available
from a removal decision.
Focusing further on Europe,
under EU laws and regulations,
there are additional
obligations on member states.
In situations of
emergency, where
there is mass influx
of displaced persons,
EU states must provide temporary
protection against return,
regardless of internal
EU arrangements
such as Dublin and
Schengen. European states
parties to the
European Convention
are prohibited from sending
refugees to other states
where the individuals
would be at risk of return
to persecution or violations
of their convention rights.
It is well accepted that
international responsibility
and burden sharing
of refugees is today
a legal obligation
on all states parties
to the Refugee Convention.
In spite of all this, the
way forward is well-known.
Under prior
international practice,
all states parties to the
Refugee Convention regime,
not just European states,
should be participating
in a UNHCR-led proposal for a
comprehensive plan of action
that sets out
numbers of refugees
that each state
agrees to accept,
the various kinds of status
that participating states are
willing to provide, minimum
standards of benefits
to be granted the refugees,
and fair refugee status
determinations in all states.
Such CPAs have been negotiated
in mass refugee flows
all over the world
from the 1970s onwards,
and well established
guidelines and criteria
exist as solid precedent to
resolve this current crisis.
These are legal
obligations, and are the key
to providing a real and durable
solution to the millions
of individual human
beings forced from home
and victimized by a crisis
not of their making.
[APPLAUSE]
-Thank you all for
showing interest.
And thank you for
Radcliffe Institute
for giving this
platform to try to build
a common understanding of the
cause of this refugee crisis.
Whenever I'm invited
to talk about Syria,
I set to prepare
some talking points,
but within minutes the
nostalgia takes me there,
where I miss my room, I
miss my library, my diary,
which should be sitting
somewhere under that rubble
now.
Each single family in Syria
has lost either a family member
or a house or belongings.
Syria has lost-- 700,000 people
were killed out of 23 million
of their population, which means
each single family, especially
in the
opposition-controlled areas,
they lost a family member.
However, as I have
just 10 minutes,
I will try to go
as fast as I can.
And bear with me if
I wasn't very fast.
So why now are we talking
about this refugee crisis?
Why now, starting from 2015?
The answer is obvious,
because some refugees
arrived to Europe.
These refugees started
in 2012 and 2013.
Syrians were daily
fleeing out of country,
and we heard the numbers
from Susan and Noel
about the numbers in the region.
But the problem is that some
countries or some people,
maybe, they don't feel
the suffering or the pain
until the risk
knocks at their door.
It is a long trip.
It is a long, risky trip.
So Syrians, they go from Syria
through the Turkish border.
Which could be
risky, because Turkey
has closed their
border since 2015,
and most families and persons,
they are crossing illegally.
Just in July, a few months
ago, a family was crossing.
Of 15 family members, 11 of them
were killed by the Turkish army
while they were trying to
cross illegally to Turkey.
And then, from Turkey
to Greece, crossing
the sea, which is
the most risky part.
And then, there are
a lot of barriers
here until they arrived to
their final destinations.
And we saw a lot of photos of
families drowning in the sea.
2,500 people drowned in the
Mediterranean in this crisis.
And we should ask
ourselves why it
seems that the conditions
they are escaping from
are worse than
drowning in the sea.
And it's not just the
only displacement.
There are other displacements.
Could be even more in numbers.
The internal
displacement, people
in Syria on a daily
basis, on a weekly basis,
we have massive population
movements escaping
from violence within Syria.
We have a lot of ad hoc camps
next to the Turkish border,
and everywhere in Syria,
containing at least
300,000 people or more.
These camps are
completely not organized,
because there is no
official presence
of the UNHCR or
international organizations
to organize these camps.
So it has the
minimum-- does not even
have the minimum level
of shelter conditions.
Most of these families
are women and children.
Some families, they had
to move several times
until they arrived to
their final destination.
This family we met in Idlib,
they moved four times,
from Damascus to rural Damascus,
and then to Homs, and then
to northern Hama, until
they arrived to this school
in Idlib, where they are
sharing the classroom
with other families.
But look at her
having some hope,
looking into her child's eyes.
The question is, why?
And the reason is obvious,
because of the Syrian crisis.
But could we define
what's happening in Syria?
It is a civil war or
a public revolution?
We have a lot of answers.
We don't have at the moment
a common understanding
of what's happening in Syria.
And maybe because of
the media, maybe because
of the political complications.
I will try as best
as I can to build
a common understanding quickly,
an intro one, as much as I can.
This map is for Syria currently.
Each color refers to a different
party, and within each color
there are different sub-parties
or different groups.
The red one is the regime where
they control the main cities.
The green one is the
opposition's, and there
are hundreds of fractions.
The black one is ISIL and
the yellow one is the Kurds.
And here, the blue one
here, is the Turks,
because even the Turks
now are in Syria.
To understand maybe
the crisis is quickly,
to review the timeline
of this crisis,
the spark started
in March 2011, when
some children from Talkalakh,
they wrote some statements
against the regime on the wall,
and the children were punished
by the intelligence agencies.
People went into
demonstrations against this,
and these demonstrations
spread out of the country.
This photo is from Hama.
But the response from
the intelligence agencies
against these protesters
was really violent,
so that's why some
commanders and soldiers
from the Syrian
Army, they refused
to participate in
these practices
against the protesters.
So they established
in 2011 something
called the Free Syrian Army.
In 2013, the Free Syrian
Army expanded and controlled
a lot of rural areas.
But the regime, they are still
controlling the main capitals.
And the Kurds, they have
some process in their areas.
In 2014, the situation
came to be complicated,
because there were a
lot of parties involved
from the regime side,
mainly Hezbollah
from Lebanon, some Shia
militias from Iraq and Iran.
And again, the Turkish
border from the other side,
the opposition's, brought
a lot of jihadists
to fight, because the war
starting from this point
maybe had some
sectorial perspectives,
because some of the parties
participated in this conflict.
And here we have in 2014
the first presence of ISIL,
but in limited areas.
In 2015, ISIL has
expanded a lot.
50% of Syria was
controlled by ISIL.
The regime shrank
to the main cities,
and the opposition's,
maybe they selected
or they were given
Idlib as the main hub.
And the Kurds, they
are in the same areas.
In 2016, here you go, we
have more external parties.
We have Russia, they have boots
on the ground with the regime,
Iran sent boots on the
ground, in addition to
Hezbollah and Iraqi militias.
And from the other
side, the US with
an international collation,
they hit areas in ISIS.
The US, they support
the Kurds, and they
are fighting against ISIS.
So that's why Kurds, they
expanded a little bit.
But because of the tension
between Turkey and the Kurds,
the Turks expanded to
have some lands here.
And there are many
other parties.
Maybe they don't have
boots on the ground,
but they are still
involved in this crisis.
So it is not a
Syrian-to-Syrian conflict.
Just recently,
Aleppo City, which
is the second-largest
city in Syria,
was completely
besieged by the regime,
putting approximately
300,000 people
under besiegement in this area.
They don't have any access
to any life services.
Just quickly, I will say quick
statements, and if it's true,
raise your hand, please, OK?
About the besieged areas.
The regime allows injured
people and medical cases
to get out of the besieged
area seeking medical help.
Is it true?
No, it is not true.
A lot of people, they die
in the besieged areas,
because they cannot
seek medical help.
Food, water, fuel are not
allowed to get in at any point.
It is true.
Medical supplies are excluded
from the restrictions.
No, it is not excluded,
even medical supplies.
The hospitals now, they
are suffering, especially
in Aleppo, from having
no medical supplies.
Aid workers and UN
agencies are allowed
to enter besieged
areas, but they
don't want to enter,
ensuring their staff safety.
Seems you have a
good understanding
about the besieged areas.
It is not true.
They are not allowed to
enter the besieged areas.
It's not just the besiegement.
There are daily targetings
of civilian infrastructure.
Just in July and
August, the health class
reported more than
30 hospitals being
destroyed, either partially or
completely, by the air strikes.
Just in one night, the 24th
of July, five hospitals out
of the 10 functioning hospitals
in Aleppo were destroyed.
And just to imagine
yourself in this hospital,
quickly, this is one
hospital in Aleppo.
So while the patients
are getting treatment,
the hospital is being targeted.
And this hospital was targeted
three times in July just,
and this hospital went
out of service completely.
Just quickly, because
we're running out of time,
education is the same story.
This hospital is our Safe
Children support Hospital
in [INAUDIBLE].
It was targeted three times.
Each time we
rehabilitated the school,
and the school was
targeted again and again.
So why do people
flee out of Syria?
My opinion is three reasons.
Violence, which we talked about.
Basic life services--
if you don't
have water, food, medical help,
for sure, you will not stay.
And personal documentation,
which is an interesting one.
Because people in
the opposition areas,
they don't have access
to the government
and they don't have
any representation.
So they cannot get
birth registrations,
death registrations,
or passports.
So they seek asylum
to have documents
showing their identity.
And then, solutions.
Is the solution by asking
countries to absorb more?
I hope it's just the
temporary solution,
because Syria is losing their
people, doctors, teachers,
who are supposed to
build the country again.
We were able to do
a lot, and we are
able to do a lot in Syria--
vaccination hospitals,
schools, even without
electricity, around candles,
and some spaces among the
violence for children to play.
But we were not able to fund all
our humanitarian response plan,
and we do have to
have a lot of advocacy
to build this
common understanding
of the Syrian crisis.
And finally, to strengthen
Syrian civil society,
because it is the
best way to-- having
the structure of
this community again,
hopefully, again
later will be a merge
between the civil society
in the regime area
and the civil society
in the opposition area.
And we had many good
examples of associations
where we are able to establish
this Idlib [INAUDIBLE]
and Idlib Governorate managing
all these health centers,
and a lot of Syrian
NGOs managing up to 23
million operations in Syria.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
-Well, thank you so
much for having me here.
I feel like I'm with
all these scholars,
and I'm just a photographer,
so instead of-- my research
basically is really my
personal impressions.
I'm originally from Lebanon,
from Palestinian parents,
and I came to the US to go to
college, to study architecture.
I really became a photographer
after September 11,
because I wanted to tell a
different story of the Middle
East.
It felt like the news was always
them and us, and I'm like,
I am them and us, and it
was very personal to me.
So I've been focusing in my
work mainly on women and girls,
and on focusing on our
universality and sameness.
But in 2014, way before we all
heard about the refugee crisis,
the Syrian crisis in
Europe and internationally,
Lebanon was dealing with that.
And I really was not actually
looking for it or anything,
but I was walking on
the streets of Beirut,
and it felt like there
were Syrian kids just
about at every corner
begging for money,
selling Kleenex,
or shining shoes,
and there was something very
utterly disturbing about it.
Lebanon is a country of about
4 and 1/2 million people.
They say now there's maybe 1
and 1/2 million refugees, some
of them not registered.
So my numbers
might not be right,
but this is the perception.
Lebanon has its own issues,
economically and politically.
There hasn't been a
president in over two years.
Even though many people are
really opening their doors
and helping the refugees,
people are also fed up.
So they make them move
away from their storefronts
and ask them to go
step somewhere else.
I started talking
to one boy, and he
was 14, which in
2014, that was the age
of my son at that point,
and he looked like my son.
And there was something
so disturbing,
that this kid
should be at school.
That's not him, but I'm making
the intro to this project.
This kid should be at school
and not on the street.
And I realized that they were
happy to be paid attention to,
so I started photographing
the kids individually.
And I feel like when you
hear about the millions,
it almost becomes abstract
and unattainable as a number.
So I'm trying to photograph
each kid by himself or herself,
and give them their identity
and their dignity back.
So I'm photographing them
just like in all of my work.
I focus on girls and women.
I'm photographing them with
the same focus and attention
that I would give anybody else.
What was interesting is I found,
as well, that all of these kids
were standing-- because
they were pushed away.
They wanted to be in
the areas of Beirut
where there would be
traffic and money,
but they were always
often pushed away
from the storefronts.
And there was something
very fascinating,
that they often stood in
front of these walls that
were covered with
graffiti, or billboards,
or different announcements.
And it felt like these walls
were breathing history,
and they had all these
layers, layers of history.
And for me, these kids became
just an anonymous layer
on these walls, and there was
something very sad about it.
So I'm going to go through the
photos and show some of them.
I mean I have their
names and their ages.
They were telling
me their stories.
But I have to say
all the stories,
sadly, blended
into one big story.
They were incredibly similar.
Most of them would
say their father
is either dead or fighting.
They didn't even know which
side he's fighting with.
But the mothers were either
begging on some other street
corner, or at home, staying
with some family members.
So these kids have been
basically on the streets,
as far as I know, since 2014.
Probably earlier.
That's when I started
doing this project.
And I found them
extreme dignified
when I photographed them.
I'm just going to tell
the story of-- this
is brand new from
this past summer.
I was actually running
in the morning,
and I passed that
young woman, who
I found stunningly beautiful.
And I don't know
how much you can
tell in the photo-- her
face was peeling, completely
burnt from the sun.
So I stopped and
started talking to her,
and I decided that
I wanted to go back.
I asked her where she would be,
and I went back, got the car,
got my camera, got her
sunscreen, and looked for her.
And so I wanted to
take her back to where
I had found her, because I
found her in a different spot.
And she got in the car with
me, which in and by itself
I found even more disturbing.
And I told her, you know
what, I'm OK, I'm a mom,
I have a daughter your
age, but you should not
get into people's cars.
I get the chills when
I tell that story.
I realized how vulnerable
all these kids are.
So I'm going to go through
them, because I also realized--
and if you see-- oh,
it's not in this one.
I have another one of her
where you could actually
see the money.
This is a shoe shining equipment
that they carry around all day.
And this girl's
name was Maya, which
is the name of my daughter,
so I have to say--
and I saw her
again a year later,
which made me happy
and sad, because it
meant she's still on
the street, but it also
meant that she was OK.
And then I started realizing--
I don't know if going too fast.
I kind of want to
make it through them.
Here you can see the
money in her hand.
I don't know if you
can see it up there,
but she's holding the
money in her hand.
This is the young-- then I
realized there was something
that a lot of these-- some
of these Syrian refugees
were actually even staying
in Palestinian refugee camps,
which in and by
itself-- I'm going
to show some of those
photos, because this was
the focus of my earlier work--
the refugee camps are in very
dire, terrible condition.
And as somebody said
before me, there's
about half a million
Palestinian refugees.
But this is a very different
story, because over there now
it's like third and
fourth generations that
are being born.
But now, so there are
some Syrian refugees
in the Palestinian refugee
camp, making the whole thing
a lot more complicated.
So this is what I'm
showing for that series,
but as we're talking
about refugees,
and the reason why
Lebanon did not
want to build camps for
the Syrian refugees,
is when they did build camps
for the Palestinian refugees,
the camps became permanent.
So what was supposed to
be a temporary structure,
now, 68 years later,
these camps are there,
they're overpopulated,
and they're
in pretty terrible condition.
So this is actually the
ID card of this woman,
and you can see how young she
was when she became a refugee.
And this is the only
piece of paper she has,
so she does not
have a citizenship.
Her paper is her refugee card.
And I'm just showing the
different generations.
I'm going to go through those.
This is in the
Palestinian refugee camp,
and these are
Palestinian refugees,
but I guess it's--
people make a life.
So the difference is these
kids, now there's a system.
There's a school
within the camps there,
so at least they're going to
school, and the structure--
the permanency of it
made it that there
is kind of a life
that's not normal,
but that at least the kids are
getting some kind of education,
and they're not on the streets.
For me, when I
started this work,
it was really for me to focus
on the universality, as well.
Like you know, at the end
of the day, she's a mom
and she's nursing her
baby, and there's nothing
more universal than that.
And here, I'm
showing to two girls.
This is kind of their house.
And here you have
the older ladies.
For me, it's like the girls
are going to turn into that.
So I'm just showing
a couple of those,
because I did work on
younger prepubescent girls,
and I was photographing girls--
I was inspired by my daughter.
I was photographing
girls in the US,
and I decided I
wanted to include
refugee girls, Palestinian
girls, Syrian girls, and girls
from Lebanon, because there's
a universality of growing up.
And so I'm showing
some of those.
And it's important for
me to put a face on them
and to see the beauty,
that these refugees
are girls before anything else.
And this, I'm doing a project
on mothers and daughters,
and this is a brand new
picture from this summer.
For me, if you see the
nails on the daughters,
every nail is different,
it's like, she's 20.
She's like any 20-year-old.
Her dreams are ahead of her.
And this is her mom, and you'd
be shocked when you found out
how old she is.
The mom is 43 years old.
I am nine years older
than this woman,
and she was treating me
like one of her daughters.
So there was something about the
permanency of life as a refugee
where, at some
point, your dreams
become-- the reality sinks in.
I believe this is the last one.
Oh, sorry.
Now I'm trying-- again, it's
about the passing of time,
so this is a 12-year-old girl
in a Palestinian refugee camp.
This is now that same
girl four years later.
And that again, this is Danya at
nine, and this again her at 13.
I'm just trying to
show that time goes by,
and life is still the
same for many people.
I'm just showing this trend.
This is a Syrian refugee girl.
And I felt like for me, one
way of trying to give back,
I work with a gallery
and we decided
to make an additional
50 of this print,
and all the money that
we make off this print
is going to the Karam
Foundation, which
is a-- I think they
do admirable work.
They're based in
Chicago, and they've
been helping Syrian
refugees, so I
thought I would just show that.
I'm sorry if I went too
fast, but this clock
is haunting me here.
[LAUGHTER]
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
-Is this working?
Yes.
Well, thank you for those
very compelling presentations.
I'm sorry we had to rush you.
Each of you could have taken
up the whole time we have,
and we would have loved it.
But in the meantime,
we've really
learned so much from you.
So I just wanted to start with
a couple of general questions,
really.
And then maybe one or
two pointed questions
to some of you, and then open
the floor for discussion.
So the first observation
and question is this.
As Susan said, it's ironic
that the countries that
are doing the most to
shelter, protect, and help
Syrian refugees are
countries that have not
signed the Refugee Convention,
that have no legal obligation
to provide the hospitality
that they're providing.
So I wonder what that says about
our international architecture,
and what it says about how we
should think moving forward
about the agreements
that we are seeking
to develop and to undertake.
And in particular, when we think
about increasing resettlement,
and when we think about moving
towards new architecture
for migration, what does the
current situation teach us?
And maybe, Noel,
I'll start with you,
because I know you've
thought a lot about the lack
of a proper framework.
But what is this
glaring reality?
Tell us.
Here we have
countries like Hungary
and the Czech Republic that
have ratified the Refugee
Convention, it was a necessary
condition of them joining
the EU, and they
are openly saying
they don't want any refugees,
they don't want any Muslims.
And at the same time
we have countries
like Lebanon and
Jordan, as we've heard,
that have not only been
hosting refugees for decades,
but that actually
haven't signed on
to the international
treaty that provides
a basis for protection.
So what does that
make you think about,
in terms of next steps
for legal architecture?
148 states have signed the
1951 Refugee Convention,
and it's true that many states,
especially surrounding Syria,
have not signed.
That is mainly to
do, historically,
with the unresolved issue of
the refugees from Palestine.
And I think we
should all-- Rania
had spoken about the
refugees from Palestine--
that unresolved refugee
situation for 67 years
is a major issue
within the Middle East.
And it is a barrier for
many of those states
to accede to the
Refugee Convention.
However, that being said, we
see that many of the states,
and in many General
Assembly resolutions,
we talk about the
extremely generous approach
of many countries
who host refugees,
albeit not being signatories
to the Refugee Convention.
The idea is really to
build on the Convention,
and not to dismantle it,
because it has actually
stood the test of time.
It has offered
protection to millions.
But to build on it and
really focus on this issue
of responsibility sharing.
It is mentioned, this concept
of international cooperation
is in the 1951 Convention.
It's mentioned in
the preamble that we
need international
cooperation to alleviate
the burden of hosting refugees.
But the systems for
doing that, we've had,
I think as Susan mentioned,
different comprehensive refugee
responses to the
Vietnamese refugee crisis,
to the Central American
refugee crisis.
But we need to do that,
not on an ad hoc basis,
but on a much more
systematic basis.
And that's what
we're working toward.
We didn't get all the way there
in a summer of negotiations,
especially in the
summer of 2016,
where the political climate
was really not very auspicious
for the negotiations.
But we have now a commitment
of states to work toward that.
And I think the challenge for
all of us, and for all of you,
is to keep the pressure on.
We have political space,
we have an opening
to work toward a better
responsibility sharing.
We need the policy ideas, we
need the focus and commitment
to get all the way there.
-Thank you so much.
Susan, did you want
to add anything?
-Yeah, I think there's
really two responses
that I have to that, picking
up on what Noel said.
The first is the observation of
how interdependent both refugee
crises are one to
the other, and how
interdependent all states
are on each other's response
to a refugee crisis.
And I think states that continue
to pretend that they can
insulate themselves,
and somehow push
a crisis onto another state,
even a neighboring state,
are really fooling themselves.
I think that time has gone.
And the pressure needs
to be on reinserting
in the political dialogue
the legal dialogue.
Because you hear all of the
politicians talking about,
well, we don't have to do this
or we don't have to do that.
But in fact, they
have bound themselves
to legal obligations, and
so that must mean something.
And it is, of course,
up to civil society
to hold our own
states accountable
to their legal obligations.
And I think the second piece
is the question of enforcement
that plagues all of
international law,
but it particularly
plagues refugee law.
And there is a provision
in the Refugee Convention
that permits states
to take violations
of the convention
against another state
to the International
Court of Justice.
Surprise, surprise,
there's never
been such a case brought to the
International Court of Justice,
but perhaps it's time.
And I have been privy to
conversations among refugee law
adjudicators, and
many of them talk
about the need for a separate
international refugee
law, refugee tribunal.
And that's coming from
adjudicators, which I
think is extremely interesting.
So on the one hand,
this interdependence--
you know, we've been
talking about the fact
that all of the
Middle Eastern states
are persistent objectors to
the refugee regime because
of the experience
with the Palestinians.
So that experience has
colored their attitude
towards all later
coming refugees.
And so without dealing with
the Palestinian question,
it isn't going to be possible
to change those states' attitude
towards the refugee regime.
So I think moving the
discussion from the political
to the legal, putting the legal
obligations front and center,
and then trying to address
some of these major gaps that
would make the protection regime
that we have much more robust.
-But I wonder if I could
just press you a little bit.
You said in your remarks
that there's an obligation
to establish a comprehensive
plan of action,
and you rightly refer to the
history from Vietnam and so on.
But why is there
such an obligation,
where does that
obligation inhere in,
and who is in a
position to impose it?
My sense is that
there's extremely little
political will,
not even to agree
on a compact of the kind
of fairly bland version
that was set out in the
Secretary General's background
paper for the 19th
of September meeting,
so where would we get the
political will for a CPA,
and how should we, as concerned
members of civil society,
be trying to build towards that?
So any thoughts on that?
-So that's really two questions,
and one is the political will,
the other is where does the
legal obligation come from.
Of course, in international law,
one of the strongest sources
of law is customary law, that
is the practice of states.
And so we can see
responsibility sharing
as a complex set
of obligations that
have become the practice of
states in major refugee crises,
starting from the 1970s CPA
in the Indo-Chinese situation,
building on that in the later
'70s and '80s [INAUDIBLE]
and the Great Lakes
Comprehensive Plan of Action,
and then a very recent one
in the former Soviet Union,
the CIS Comprehensive
Plan of Action.
So we are actually
finding states responding
in more and more
sophisticated ways,
and they're building on
formal legal obligations,
not just from the Refugee
Convention, but from,
for example, the
temporary protection norm,
which has now become
formalized almost everywhere.
In the US, we have
temporary protected status
built into our Immigration
Nationality Act.
In Europe, we have
the EU-wide directive
on temporary protection,
that should, by the way,
be triggered by
the Syrian crisis,
because it's precisely
this kind of crisis that
should trigger the directive.
So it's a multi-layered,
complex response
that I would argue is now
formalized as state practice.
And I think it's customary
international law.
Now, where should it come from?
Like most of the other
comprehensive plans of actions,
they've been driven
by the UNHCR,
by putting a
formula on the table
and then pressing
states to begin
a rather complex short and
longer-term admission process,
and dividing up
responsibility in that way.
I think it's not a mystery.
We have to generate
the political will.
But I think the legal obligation
is now, at this point,
quite clear.
-Let me switch a little bit
from the policy and legal
to the more human and
humanitarian side of things.
So Abdulkarim, I
wanted to ask you,
you showed some of the images
of the bombing of hospitals,
and several of us
here, just actually
in Boston in the last few
days have been to talks
given by doctors from
Syria documenting
unbelievable attacks.
According to one surgeon,
every single hospital in Syria
has been bombed at least once.
And he also said that now
people in the rebel groups,
or in the opposition groups,
are saying to the doctors
and to the medical
personnel, please
don't come near us, because
if you come near us,
we're definitely
going to be a target.
So how do you explain that?
Why do you think
that's happening?
I'd just be interested to know.
Not only is it such a
fundamental and gross violation
of international
norms, it's also--
and please correct
me if I'm wrong--
but I think it's
pretty unprecedented.
This degree of
willful destruction
of bonafide medical
services that are neutrally
administering medical help to
both sides in the conflict,
admitting anybody who
needs medical care.
How do you, as
someone who's actually
going in and out
of Syria, dealing
with the humanitarian crisis,
how do you explain this?
Why are people-- what
do people say about
this specific targeting?
-Actually, starting from
the beginning of the crisis,
there was enormous pressure
on the medical staff
from both sides.
So starting from 2011, when some
medical staff, they were trying
to provide help to the
people from the other side,
they were receiving a lot of
pressure from the regime side.
And at the same time, medical
staff in the opposition,
they are under enormous pressure
from specific fraction groups
if they treat people
from other groups.
So the concept was there since
the beginning of the crisis.
And maybe recently,
especially in 2016,
we are seeing this
increased targeting.
It seems that a lot of targeting
of the civilian infrastructure
are linked to the military
techniques of all the parties
involved in this conflict.
Because it seems whenever
they besieged any area,
then they will start to target
the civilian infrastructure,
and mainly hospitals
and medical staff,
to push people to flee
out of these areas.
And then they can have
some demographic changes.
And unfortunately, that's what
happened in several areas,
in Homs and [INAUDIBLE]
in 2014, and the same
happened this year.
Three population movements,
or forced movements,
happened from Al-Zabadani, from
[? Maldonia, ?] and recently
from Al-Ward and Homs.
So they besiege the
area and then target
the civilian
infrastructure, so people,
they don't have options.
They should leave.
And especially the
medical services,
because it is essential
for the people who
stayed to have medical help,
because they are under daily
targeting by air strikes.
So without having
medical services,
they are more likely to
flee out of their home.
So these are the interpretations
that we heard from the people
in Syria, that it seems
that it is like a target
specifically within
besieged areas.
-Noel, did you have any
insights on this aspect
from a UNHCR perspective?
Because it's such a fundamental
violation of international law
that just dispassionately, even
in other very bitter conflicts,
this kind of targeting
hasn't happened.
So I just wondered, is
this something that's
been taken up even with the
UN as experts are meeting,
or has it gone
beyond that point?
-Yeah.
And what we haven't
talked about today
is that a part of any
comprehensive solutions
has to be a solution to the war.
There is not-- the
former High Commissioner
of Refugees, who's
just been-- we're
very proud he is now
the new Secretary
General, Antonio Guterres,
will start his term in January.
But he kept saying, there
is no humanitarian solution
to the war in Syria, there
is only a political solution.
And peace is the only solution.
And what you can say about
these horrible violations
of international
humanitarian law
is that, as Karim
has already said,
it's a major cause
of displacement.
It is targeted toward
increasing displacement.
And we can build better
systems of receiving refugees
in neighboring countries, we
can increase resettlement,
but we're not going to
solve the Syrian refugee
problem in that way.
We need to find peace in
Syria, as difficult as that is.
-Thank you.
Rania, I wanted to ask
you about your really
compelling and
beautiful pictures.
You said that you started
photographing the children when
you realized that they
liked-- they welcomed
the attention, in a way.
But there are concerns that
many of us have about the way
in which children
are always used
to highlight, and sometimes
to sensationalize, tragedy.
And of course, the
technical question
is, how does one get
consent, is there
a parent who's giving consent,
what happens to the images?
But the broader
question is, what
is the role that these images
then play in the world,
and how are they controlled?
And I am sure you've
thought about this.
I'd love to have just your
reflections on the-- I
guess its tension, the
pluses and the minuses.
Obviously, there are
compelling and they involve us,
but at the same time there's
a sense of maybe some sort
of ethical concerns.
So I'd just love to hear
your thoughts on that.
-You know, really, for
me, I photographed them
like I photograph my own kids.
And I felt like they were--
it was important for me
to give them a face.
So it was done with
a good intention,
and I didn't think beyond
that, I have to say.
I'm not using-- CNN asked
me to put them on TV.
I didn't agree, because
the kids did not want
to have their pictures on TV.
So I am trying to use
it for the right reason
and the right context.
I have an exhibit-- I mean I'm
not paid to do those images.
This was doing it
because I want to do it.
I wasn't hired by anybody.
So I'm very careful, they're
protected by my copyright.
I'm very careful
where they end up.
And I'm only showing them
within the context of my work.
Now, in the Middle East, in
general, I dumped the consent
a long time ago.
Because asking people
for consent makes
people freak out like they're
signing their life away.
And I realized it's a
very different culture,
and once the trust
is established,
this was more important than
giving them a piece of paper
and signing it.
As soon as I gave
them the paper,
the whole trust in the
relationship was altered.
So in the camps, I've
never asked for anything.
I go back, I give them
pictures, I work with the NGOs.
I don't want to have
an exchange of money,
because I don't want it to be
about paying for the image.
So I give some
money to the NGOs,
and I tell them I want them to
help the few families that I
build relationships
with over the year.
Now, this is coming from
the right intentions,
and I'm trying to be
as protective of where
the images end up as I can.
-Thank you.
I mean it's an interesting
question, because of course,
as scholars and academics,
we're very circumscribed in what
we can do.
We have--
-Oh, absolutey.
---to get permission from--
-And then-- and
the kids, really, I
felt like most people did not--
one time I was photographing--
I'm almost embarrassed
to tell this story,
but you have to put it
in the context of people
are fed up in Lebanon.
But I was
photographing that boy,
and I was kind of in the
middle of the street.
It was a small alley, and this
guy came speeding toward me.
So I kind of jumped
backwards, and I
yelled in Arabic,
what's wrong with you?
And he said, you
deserve it, why are
you photographing those dogs?
So it was-- most people do
not treat them like that.
But I realized for me, somebody
to treat them with respect
and pay attention to
them and talk to them,
and I would go buy
them candy and water,
it's about building
a relationship.
They would be happy to see me
when I came back the next day.
-Thank you.
The last question
I'm going to ask--
and maybe people can start
thinking about their questions
while I do-- is about the
question that several of you
raised about documents.
So Abdulkarim, you said that
one of the reasons people leave
is because they don't
have a relationship
with the government.
And Susan, you said that
people are irregular, illegal,
they don't have a legal status.
And we know from
work that many of us
are engaged in that many
of the children lack
birth registration.
Now many of the Syrian
children are actually
becoming stateless, which
has lifelong consequences.
So why can't the advances that
we've made with new technology
be used to create
a simple mechanism?
Not beyond the intelligence of
many, many people in this town
to create a simple
mechanism of having
a fingerprint, and a
date, and a photograph.
Are people trying
to think about this?
Because it's been talked about
for at least a year and a half,
this idea of really ensuring
that children are not
undocumented, that children are
not stateless, that children do
have some record
of their identity,
and, ideally, of their birth.
Do either of you,
maybe in particular,
know whether any of
this is happening?
And if not, why not?
-Should I start just
describing the situation
in Syria and in Turkey?
It is not about technology,
actually, at all.
Because even in Turkey,
they do have the technology,
but they struggle in the
birth registration example.
If, for example, I have
a daughter in Turkey,
I'll struggle a lot to
have a birth certificate.
And if I don't have
a birth certificate,
I cannot get the Syrian
nationality, even.
So even in Turkey,
there is a problem
related to the
personal documentation
or personal state.
In Syria, there were some
ideas and initiatives
by the local councils.
And local councils,
they are kind
of ad hoc structures in each
village and each city in Syria.
They are from the
local people, kind
of representing their
people, the village itself,
and trying to provide
the services there.
So some of these
local councils, they
started recording
especially the births
and deaths, and properties,
and some other information.
But actually, they
don't have the support.
There was maybe one project
through the system coordination
unit supported,
I think, by OFDA,
maybe at some point,
or other donors,
to support the local councils to
do kind of governance structure
to them.
But I think they didn't receive
proper support to do that.
-OK.
Well, thank you very
much, all of you.
So if anybody would
like to ask a question,
please line up behind
the microphone.
And as Dean Cohen said,
just give us your name
and ask your question.
-Thank you very much.
I'm Hala Zreiqat, one of
the Radcliffe Fellows.
I am Jordanian by origin,
but live in Australia.
The question I would
like to ask is,
what's the panel view on the
position of the Gulf region,
in terms of opening their
doors to the refugees in Syria
or Palestine?
The reason I ask
about that is I,
myself, quite often ask
this question-- why should
Europe, America-- not
Australia at the moment,
they're closing their
borders, I think--
but why should we open
the doors for refugees
when you have the money and
the space in the Gulf region?
-Thank you very much.
Yeah.
Let's take one more
question, and then we'll
ask the panel to respond.
Yes?
-It's an interesting match
to the last question.
My name is Cheryl
Hamilton, I'm the Director
of Partner Engagement at
the International Institute.
We resettle 640 refugees
here in the region.
And I have one request, which
is we just found out, of course,
we're going to resettle
25,000 more refugees,
but there was no financial
increase provided.
So actually, we have less money
to do the same and almost twice
as much work.
But my interesting
question is, I really
admired how you
said that we don't
talk enough about all
refugee populations.
We're resettling right now
only six Syrian families,
but we have 55% of our
cases that are Congolese.
How do we advocate well
on behalf of all refugee
populations, not ignoring
this amazing work you're
doing today?
-Thank you so much.
So Noel, would you like to
take one of those questions?
-Yeah, I would just
underline really
the importance of the
point that you've just
made, about advocating well
on behalf of all refugee
populations.
You do perceive, especially at
the UN, a kind of a jealous,
my refugee situation is getting
more attention than yours.
And that's not
just a petty issue,
because it's an
issue about funding.
We have very, very
critical underfunding
of many, many
refugee situations.
And it's now about the sense
that if you sort of put
your refugees under
pressure, that's a good way
to get more financial support.
And we don't want to go
down that road, where
in order for a country to get
more support for its refugees,
it needs to threaten to send
them back to their own country,
for example.
Refugees, there needs to be
some principle of equity.
And so as much as
we need to talk
about the situation in Syria, I
think in all of these contexts,
we need to keep also bring up
situations like what's going on
in Congo, or South
Sudan, or not to forget
about Afghanistan and Somalia.
Those poor people have been
refugees for 20, 30 years.
And then the
Palestinians, as well.
So it is very important to keep
all of these issues together,
because that helps to improve
the protection for all.
-Thank you.
Susan, do you want to tackle
the question about the Gulf?
-Yes.
And actually, the
Gulf states, the UAE
has agreed to take
a few thousand.
I think it's no more than 45
or something thousand Syrians.
And I don't know the details
of what the actual status is
that they're planning to
give, because they're also not
parties to the
Refugee Convention.
So it would have to be by
memorandum of agreement
with the UNHCR what the
parameters of that agreement
would be.
But I think you make a
really good point, which
is that in most of
the discussions,
the Gulf has been left off.
And I think because of the
sense that the Gulf has never
been welcoming to refugees, and
has a huge problem of migrants,
migrant workers, who
have been struggling
to get some kind of status and
basic rights for themselves
as workers.
So that's an ongoing
struggle with the Gulf.
But I think it's a
really good point,
and there needs to be
much more attention paid.
Now, the Gulf states are
paying a lot of money
to Turkey in particular, but
also to Jordan, for the camps
and for the refugees there.
But of course, that's
not a substitute
for actually accepting them.
-I think also, sadly,
religion plays a big role
in the Middle East right now.
Palestinian Christians
were given citizenship,
Palestinian Muslims ended
up in the refugee camps.
And I think now the whole--
a lot of Lebanese Shia
are not given visas anymore to
go work in the Gulf countries,
like Dubai and the
UAE and Saudi Arabia.
And so there's a
whole other layer
of dirty politics and religion
that's playing in that as well.
-Thank you.
Yes, next question, please.
-Hi, my name is Ana.
I was just wondering.
So at the beginning
of this whole panel,
it was mentioned that a
refugee crisis couldn't really
become possible until the
creation of the nation state.
And so I was just wondering,
and this isn't directed
towards anyone in
particular, but does
today's international
refugee crisis speak
to the constructedness
of the nation state
and that borders are
so porous, or does
a state's lack of
response or desire
to protect the nation state
speak to its solidity?
-Thank you.
Yeah, and we'll have
one more question.
-I'm Abigail English and I'm
a former Radcliffe Fellow.
In your opening
remarks, Jackie, you
mentioned that many
of the refugees
are not part of families,
are traveling on their own.
And so many of them are
children or adolescents.
And I'm wondering
whether any of you
could comment from
a humanitarian,
or a human rights, or
a legal perspective,
what the potential
opportunities are
for protecting those
young people who
are traveling on their own.
Thank you.
-Thank you very much, Abigail.
OK, so the first
question was really,
what does this
refugee crisis say
about the viability or the
continuing of the nation
state and the notion
that every state has
its own sovereign right
to protect its borders,
given how, in a way, borders
have become more porous?
So is this signaling
some sort of change,
or is this signaling
just a retrenchment,
in terms of a humanitarian
commitment, I suppose?
So would anybody like
to tackle that question?
OK, Noel, go ahead.
-Maybe I'll tackle that.
If there is change, it's as the
Arabs would say, shway shway.
It's very slow.
Because look, in the
negotiations in New York,
it's very clear that
states want to maintain
control of their borders.
And this is the
political environment
in which we're living in, where
there's more and more talk
about border control, and this
association of people coming
in with all sorts of the ills.
But at the same time, we
did have the moment-- which,
it's very small--
but an agreement
that now we're going
to discuss migration
at the United Nations.
Before, that topic was
actually taboo at the UN.
That we're going to bring the
International Organization
for Migration into
the United Nations--
before it was a separate.
The UN didn't have a
migration organization.
So that's a step.
And that we're going to have
an international conference
on migration.
The idea to have an
intergovernmental process
on migration, that goes
back at least to 1994,
and member states would
never agree to it.
So the fact that
they agreed to it
now suggests some recognition
that migration isn't something
that states manage
on their own, it's
something that
needs to be governed
within the international system.
So maybe a little bit
of a shift, but not
a big philosophical
transformation at this point.
-Thank you.
Yeah.
And the question about children,
particularly unaccompanied
children, and what
protections are available
and what protections
are being provided,
does anybody want
to address that?
-I can address what
I saw in Lebanon.
The kids were very vulnerable.
I don't think there was--
as far as I could tell.
But again, it's
something from my--
there was no
protection whatsoever.
I was told they
come in a big truck,
and they get dropped off
early in the morning,
and they're expected to
just bring money back.
A five-year-old would give me
a name, and would come back
and I heard her
talking to another guy,
and she had told me
her name was Samira,
and now she's talking to the
guy, and he said, OK, bye, Aya.
And I told her, oh, you told
me your name was Samira.
And she whispers,
I'm lying to him.
And obviously she's
lying to me, but I
realized they learn to
be very street smart.
And she was five.
So they felt extremely
vulnerable to me.
The girls were very beautiful
and very vulnerable,
and the boys I felt
were as vulnerable.
This is the next generation,
and these kids are not
being educated, and
I worry about them
on the streets for too
long, ended up being
recruited in the wrong places.
They are easy targets.
-Just quickly address
that from two aspects.
One is the what legal
protections are available,
and the second is
that it's actually
becoming an enormous crisis.
We've started a project on
the pushbacks from Greece
and Bulgaria this
year with my students,
and my Greek
colleagues have been
documenting that there
are thousands of migrants
who are disappearing.
After arriving on
these terrible voyages,
they are somehow disappearing.
The NGOs are reaching
some of them,
and then they can't find them.
So that's an enormous issue.
And Greece has been
dealing with detentions,
and they've been
detaining minors.
Bulgaria also is
So the problem of
tracking these kids,
and having a mechanism
of registration,
and serious protection to
provide for their needs
immediately when they arrive,
is a very, very big challenge.
Having said that,
there's plenty of law
on special protections across
the EU under European law.
The Human Rights
Convention, the Convention
on the Rights of
a Child do provide
for very specific
obligations on states
to protect minors and
unaccompanied minors.
In the US, we have both
trafficking protections
under our immigration law
that apply to children
and also something called
Special Immigrant Juvenile
Status, which allows children
to get immigration status
once the fact that they
don't have a parent taking
care of them is documented
and registered by the courts.
So it's not a problem
of lack of law,
but again that it's
not being carried out.
-Thank you.
Yes, next question.
-If so many refugees--
-Could you just give
us your name, please?
-Oh, my name is [? Mishiti. ?]
If so many refugees
are fleeing their
countries, what's happening
to the country's economy?
It seems that the countries
are entering a poverty
cycle, in which poor economies
cause people to seek refuge
in other countries, which in
turn makes the economy worse.
What is the solution to this?
-Thank you so much.
[LAUGHTER]
Nice, simple question.
Thank you.
And we'll have
one more question.
Thank you.
-Thank you.
My name is [? Gilda. ?]
May 2015 to September 2015,
I must have kept
every paper clipping
from Financial
Times that focused
on the pictures of the refugee
crisis, the migration crisis.
2015 September, I stopped,
because all I could do
was cry over those
paper clippings.
Picking up from what perspective
that Susan mentioned,
within the confines of the
bureaucracy of the laws
and the rules that limit us from
giving any humanitarian help,
as a mother, as a
woman, as a common man,
what powers do I
have to participate
in this humanitarian crisis?
How can it be more easy for me
to help without bureaucracy?
Thank you.
-Thank you so much for that
really important question.
So first of all, the question
about this escalating
cycle of poverty is the fact
that refugees are leaving,
leading to population
depletion and greater poverty,
and a vicious circle.
Anybody want to address that
and comment on that point?
Yeah, Abdulkarim.
-Actually, that's the root
of the crisis in Syria,
and as I mentioned,
Syria now is losing
their people who are supposed
to build the country again.
And the problem is that the
links between these people when
fleeing out of the
country and Syria
are really becoming
less and less.
And for the new
generations, maybe they
are not linked anymore
with the country.
In the neighboring
countries-- just in Turkey,
they recorded approximately
200,000 or 300,000 new births
for Syrians through
the last five or six
years who have
never been in Syria,
and maybe they are linked
to Turkey more than Syria.
So it is really a serious issue.
So I think when
studying the polices
for maybe the UN agencies
and for the international
organizations, when they are
designing their intervention,
I think we should make a
link between the refugees,
especially in the
neighboring countries,
and anywhere in the world,
and their home country.
At least if there
is any stability
in the future,
these people, they
can come back to participate
in raising the economy
of their country again.
-Yeah, as Noel said in
the beginning, of course,
most refugees-- nearly all
refugees-- want to go home,
but where you have
acute conflict,
it's just impossible
to even imagine that.
And so this task
of rebuilding then
becomes really
elusive, so I think
it's a very important point.
Anybody want to address
the point about the--
-I want to add to that.
---civil society and
what individuals can do.
Yeah?
-I mean I want to add to him,
as well, because I see it
from Lebanon.
I mean Lebanon barely
survived the civil war,
and it's been a brain drain.
A little people who could
afford it left the country,
and now you have half a
million Palestinian refugees,
about over a million,
maybe a million and a half
Syrian refugees.
The garbage is not
getting picked up,
there's no electricity,
and no water,
so the problem becomes worse.
So I don't know how--
it's bigger than Lebanon.
So it's something where
the international community
needs to be involved.
And I found, as of
civil societies,
there are a lot of local
NGOs who do incredible work.
And I give them so much credit
than all the politicians,
because they volunteer,
people donate clothes,
and they do makeshift
schools for them.
I think people in the US
are nervous donating money
to institutions in
the Middle East, which
is why I recommend looking
up the Karam Foundation.
The woman is from Aleppo.
Do you know her, Lena--
-I heard about her, yeah.
I know of the work that they do.
-Yeah, so they do a
lot of work in Turkey.
And then, for me, when
I was raising money,
I wanted it to go to
Lebanon, so they kind of
were telling me where
the money was going,
and they found the
local NGOs in Lebanon
who help the Karam Foundation
who could work with them.
So it's a very transparent way
of donating money if you're
in the US, to look at them.
I think they do fantastic work.
So that's one
recommendation I have.
They probably have more.
-OK, we nearly out of time.
We are out of time.
So I'll quickly take
the last two questions,
and then wrap up.
Yes, sir?
-Do you mind if I just
answer how you can help,
because I think that's a--
-No, sure.
Absolutely.
---really, really important one.
We spent two years, my
student teams and I,
mapping what was happening
in Turkey and Jordan
and Lebanon and Egypt
to all of the refugees,
not just the Syrians, though
we were focused on the Syrians.
And we produced a
very large report
that actually lays
out a way forward,
built on concrete
state obligations,
including here in
the United States.
And when we first
started advocating around
that report in
Washington, we basically
got the answer that nobody
gives a blank blank about Syria.
I think that's changed.
And I think one of the most
powerful delegations that
is sympathetic to refugees is
right here in Massachusetts.
Our congressional
representatives
include people
like Jim McGovern,
who are absolutely phenomenal.
He's worked on refugee issues
way back from the Central
American crises in
the '80s onwards,
and Capuano, Elizabeth Warren.
These are people who,
if you take an ask,
and join the refugee
organizations around Boston
who are asking not only
for increased resettlement,
but for temporary
protection statuses
for new kinds of status similar
to the ones that Canada has.
Private sponsorship.
That would be
absolutely incredible
if we could get something
like private sponsorship
here, and allow the Arab and
Syrian communities to sponsor
people from Syria, and the
same for Somalis and others.
It would be a small step.
A huge step in the
right direction,
but a very small and
modest thing to do.
In addition, there are
lots of organizations
here in Boston working on
the Syrian refugee crisis.
There's an organization
called New Day Syria which
is trying to help the
refugees once they're here,
finding housing, plugging
them into social services.
We have an amazing network
of refugee organizations
right here in Boston.
You can plug into any of them.
And look at our report, please.
-Thank you so much, Susan.
Yes, OK.
-Hi, there.
My name is Jeff Laurenti, with
the somewhat aging reunion
class of 1971.
I was struck by
Rania's observation
that there are often
political agendas that
work their way through the
publicity given to one refugee
crisis rather than another, and
Noel's caution against having
refugee situations in
competition, perhaps
in part driven by those
political agendas.
You mentioned Afghanistan, and I
recall that three decades ago--
people of our reunion
class might remember--
there was an enormous
amount of press attention
to Afghan refugees
when it was against
the Soviet intervention.
And for the past
18 years, 17 years,
since the American
intervention, no press
stories at all about the
Afghan refugees in Pakistan.
A lot of press attention to
Syrian refugees by people
who feel revulsion against
the brutality of the Assad
government, maybe
seeking or hoping
for a more robust Western
intervention, but on the Congo,
on South Sudan, on
all these refugee
situations in Africa, none.
When these refugees
make their way
across the Mediterranean
from Libya into Italy,
there's a blurring, an elision
of whether they are migrants
or refugees, and
whether they could all
have the door closed to them.
So since your summit dealt
with refugees and migrants,
to what extent are we
seeing an elision of the two
in the international
debate, to what extent
do we need international
law to maintain
very clear distinctions,
and how do we then
hope to have those distinctions
actually implemented?
-Thank you very much.
Yes, and the last question.
-I don't have a
question, but I would
like to add something, please.
One of the biggest countries
that help Syrian refugees
is Saudi Arabia.
And given that Saudi Arabia
has welcomed Saudi refugees,
and has hosted millions
and millions and millions
of Syrian refugees, and the
Saudi the government gave
them visas to stay
inside Saudi Arabia,
and gave them opportunities to
treatment in Saudi hospitals,
and study in schools, and--
-Thank you.
---universities,
and give them work.
Yes.
That's all.
-OK, thank you.
Thank you so much.
So the question about
this blending, this
is the final question,
about should we
be keeping refugee and
migration regimes separate,
or are they being fused
together [INAUDIBLE]?
-I would say, first of all, we
have to start from the premise
that whether you're a refugee or
a migrant, you're a human being
and you enjoy human rights,
regardless of where you are.
So there are legal distinctions
between refugees and migrants,
and in the summit those
legal distinctions
are maintained, because
there is a difference
between-- the situation
of refugees is different,
in that if they're
returned to their homes,
they will face persecution
or danger that will affect
their life or health.
And that is different from the
situation of a migrant, who
may go home to a difficult
situation, but perhaps not one
that would cause him to suffer
persecution, or put his life
or health at risk.
So within the legal regime the
distinctions are being made,
but there is more attention
to the issue of migrants
who do not qualify
as refugees, but who
do need significant-- do need
human rights protections,
and may need special assistance
because of the horrible dangers
that they face, either as
victims of trafficking,
they may need protection
as unaccompanied children,
they may need special support
because of the dangers
that they've faced.
For example, in those horrible
boats where people's lives
are being put at risk.
So while the legal
distinctions are maintained,
it is important to extend
the protections that
are necessary to each.
But I want to say one more thing
about how we can get involved,
because I think we've
touched on civil society
involvement and
financial support,
and we've talked about
the political side.
Another part of it,
and this comes really
from the consultations
that we did with refugees
before the summit, the one
thing that refugees have said--
the question was,
what do you want
world leaders to know
about refugees that they
just critically misunderstand?
And we asked that question
in a lot of different groups
of refugees, and the answer
was almost always the same,
is that we have a lot to offer.
We are good at what we
do, we're professionals.
So one more thing that you can
do is you can hire a refugee.
Because look, refugees
are really-- they
can be fantastic employees.
We have lots of
data to show that.
And they're not a
burden on society.
Refugees don't like to
be considered a burden.
That term burden sharing
in the 1951 Convention
is annoying to most.
-Responsibility sharing.
-Well, we tried to
change it responsibility,
but that's a whole, long debate.
Member states don't
agree to that.
The word in the
convention is burden,
but refugees don't like
it, and I understand that.
So hire a refugee and I
don't think you'll regret it.
-Thank you so much.
[LAUGHTER]
-Well, let me just say this
has been a fabulous, if
sobering symposium,
and I want to thank you
all very much for being here.
And I want to ask the
audience to join me
in thanking you with applause.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]